Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Alkış)
Size bugün, umutla ilgili konuşmak için
belki de beni seçmelerinin
ne kadar yanlış olduğunu anlatacağım.
(Kahkaha)
Hayatımın o kadar büyük bir bölümünde
umutlarımın kırılmasına izin verdim ki,
ama her seferinde yeniden
umutlanacak kadar da ahmak oldum.
Böyle bir, iki uçlu hayatım oldu galiba
ta ki müzikle ve sizlerle
müzik yolculuğunun içinde buluşana kadar.
Size ilk doğum günümü
anlatmak istiyorum hatırladığım.
Annemle birlikte
bir kırtasiyenin önünden geçiyoruz,
böyle mavi gözlü,
pembe ipek kurdeleli böyle
bir Van kedisi görüyorum peluş vitrinde
ve anneme diyorum ki,
"Anne ne olur, doğum günü hediyem
olarak bana bu kediyi al."
Hayatta hatırladığım ilk keskin umudum.
En büyük umudum,
o kediye sahip olma arzusu o sırada.
Annem de diyor ki,
"Bizim gücümüz ona yetmez,
ama yanındaki
küçük kutup ayısını alabiliriz."
Küçük kutup ayısını da
bayağı gazlı içecekler
bedava filan dağıtıyor o zamanlarda,
yani benim için hiçbir anlamı yok
onun hediye olarak.
Çok üzülüyorum, aradan bir süre geçiyor
ve önüme güzel bir
doğum günü paketi geliyor büyükçe
belli ki içinde kutup ayısı yok,
diyorum ki "Kesin kedi çıkacak"
ve kedi çıkıyor.
Ve ben o kediyle hiçbir zaman
oynamaktan keyif almıyorum,
hiçbir zaman o kediyi sevmiyorum,
hep kütüphanemin üstünde duruyor.
Buradan, insan olarak ne kadar ikiyüzlü
olduğumu anlıyorum ilk çocukken.
Yani bir şeyi umut ediyorum,
ona istediğim zaman istediğim şekilde
sahip olamadım diye
sonradan sahip olduğumda
onunla ilgilenmiyorum.
Aradan bir zaman daha geçiyor;
baktım bana peluşlardan bana hayır yok,
ilkokula başladığım zaman
arkadaşım olacak, dostum olacak,
sonunda oyun arkadaşlarım olacak
diye çok mutlu oluyorum.
Çünkü tek çocuğum o sırada,
terasta kendi kendime konuşuyorum filan.
İlkokuldayken arkadaşlarımın
olacağından çok umutluyum,
fakat bir gün beni kandırıyorlar,
diyorlar ki "Hep birlikte
çeşmeye kadar koşacağız Kalben,
çeşmeye ilk sen varacak olursan,
seni arkadaş grubumuza alıyoruz."
Çeşmeye kadar gerçekten
Usain Bolt gibi koşuyorum
(Kahkaha)
ve ben çocukken de iri biriydim,
yani hani "bayağı" bir terliyorum,
yoruluyorum filan o sırada,
ama koşuyorum ve geri dönüp baktığım zaman
benimle koşmadıklarını görüyorum
arkadaşlarımın.
Bana kahkahalarla güldüklerini görüyorum.
Yine umutlarım kırılıyor
insanlardan yana bu sefer.
13 yaşına geliyorum; baktım
peluşlardan da, insanlardan da hayır yok
artık ergenlik dönemindeyim,
yeni bir umudum var: Uçmak.
Her gece göğe bakıyorum
ve kendi tanrıma yakarıyorum,
umudum uçmak, uçmak istiyorum.
Fiziksel olarak bunun
imkânsız olduğunu bilsem de,
uçmaya kafayı taktım,
en büyük umudum uçmak.
Sonra uçamadığım için,
Dünya'ya inmek durumunda kalıyorum
ve liseyi bitiriyorum,
iyi bir okula başlıyorum.
O iyi okulu bitirirken çok iyi bir
mesleğimin olacağını düşünüyorum,
iyi bir mesleğim olmuyor.
Sektörden sektöre geziyorum,
bir kadın olarak erkeklerle
eşit maaş kazanamadığımı öğreniyorum.
Efendime söyleyeyim, satış temsilcisi
olduğum zaman insanların
"Öğleden sonra bir viski içer miyiz?"
gibi garip sorularıyla karşılaşıyorum.
(Kahkaha)
Lojistik sektöründe
yönetici asistanlığı yapıyorum.
(Alkış) Çok tatlısınız, yapmayın.
Lojistik sektörüne giriyorum,
yönetici asistanlığı yapacağım,
yöneticimin yanında böyle duran
insan olacağımı zannederken
bulaşık yıkarken buluyorum kendimi.
(Kahkaha)
Sonra diyorum ki,
"Sana buralarda hayır yok, sen okula dön."
Ve akademiye dönüyorum,
yüksek lisansımı yapmaya karar veriyorum.
Rahmetli annem için
anı saklamanın yolları üzerine,
yadirgârlar üzerine
bir tez vermeye karar veriyorum.
O sırada dünya güzeli insanlarla
tanışıyorum o tezi yazarken
ve o insanlar bana çok umut verdiler,
öncelikle bunu söylemek istiyorum.
Eş zamanlı olarak,
gitar çalarken kapıma polis gönderen
komşuma da buradan sesleniyorum.
(Kahkaha)
O bana hiç umut vermedi, aksine
umutlarımı kıran insanlardan olmuştur,
ama umuyorum görüyordur şu an.
(Kahkaha)
Akademide ise aslında
beklediğim özgürlüğün olmadığını,
yine birilerine karşı dobra olamayacağımı,
yine birilerini
hoş tutmak zorunda olduğumu;
yine fikirlerimdense, o güne kadar
düşünmüş insanların fikirlerini
bir araya getirerek
yazılar yazabileceğimi anlıyorum.
Hatta şeyi sorduğumu çok iyi hatırlıyorum
tez danışmanıma,
"Bütün tezi ben yazmıyor muyum?" diye.
Hani alıntı yapıyormuşuz filan sürekli.
Akademide de kendimce
bir umut kırıklığına uğruyorum.
(Kahkaha) (Alkış)
Ve Türkiye'nin başkenti olan,
Melih başkanın artık terk etmeyi
başardığı dünya güzeli Ankara'da...
(Alkış)
...sokakların nasıl değiştiğini,
kadınların nasıl içlerine kapandığını,
erkeklerin nasıl daha agresif olduğunu,
insanların nasıl iş yerlerine giderken
mutsuzlaştığını,
parkların nasıl küçüldüğünü,
evlerin nasıl huzursuzlaştığını izlediğim
bir sekiz seneden sonra;
işsiz olduğum için,
kendi kiram ve faturamı
artık ödeyebilecek bir durumum
artık olmadığı için
yüksek lisans mezunu biri olarak,
İstanbul'a taşınmaya karar veriyorum.
En büyük umudum 25 yaşında,
İstanbul'a gelip faturamı ödeyebilmek.
Yani hiç görmediğim
bir evin kirasını vermek
ve faturalarını ödemek için
İstanbul'a geliyorum.
İstanbul'da yine çok farklı sektörlerde
çalışmaya başlıyorum.
Yazarlık yaparken örneğin,
senaryo yazarlığı,
bu durumu unutamıyorum:
Böyle doksan sayfa filan yazmışım,
inanılmaz heyecanlıyım
böyle gecelerce uyumamışım.
Sonra sevgili yapımcımız geldi,
senaryoyu okudu
ve dedi ki, "Buna gülmezler"
ve attı.
Bütün umutlarımın o an
çok net olarak crash sesleriyle,
cam kırıkları hâlinde
parçalandığını hatırlıyorum.
Yani bir insan olarak
ne kadar çok çalışsak da, uğraşsak da,
kendimize inansak da,
bazı konularda iyi olduğumuza kibirli
olmamaya çalışarak inanmış olsak da,
yine de birileri gelip
"Bu yeterince iyi değil,"
"Bu birilerini güldürmez,"
"Bunu satamayız,"
"Bu çok uzun,"
"Bu çok kısa"
"Buraya biraz renk katalım,"
falan diyebildiği için,
umutlarımız sürekli kırılabiliyordu.
Bunu İstanbul'da da görmeye devam ettim.
İşte bir siyasi partinin
sosyal medya kampanyasını yaparken
özellikle yerel seçimlerde,
bütün umutlarım o zaman kırıldı.
2014 yılıydı sanırım, bazı şeyleri
çok daha yakından görme şansım oldu
ve ne yazık ki
umutlarımın kırılmasına izin vermişim.
Şimdi geri dönüp baktığım zaman
keşke hiç izin vermeseydim
ve her seferinde tekrar böyle
ayağa kalksaydım diyorum ama
hep iş değiştirdim, hep alan değiştirdim.
Hep kendim için
başka bir şey arayıp durdum.
Yani umutlarımın kırılmadığı,
beni tuhaf bulmayan,
bana bu satmaz demeyen
bir yer aradım hayatta her zaman.
Yani çeşmeye koşarken benimle birlikte
koşabilecek insanları aradım.
Ya da ben uçmak isterken
bana aptal gözüyle değil,
"Birlikte uçabiliriz" deyip elimi tutup
benimle belki de o sırada
sadece duran insanları aradım.
Ve bu yolculuğun sonunda da
müzik çıktı karşıma.
(Alkış)
Her zaman oradaydı ve de.
8 yaşında da oradaydı, 13 yaşında
ilk gitarımı aldığımızda da oradaydı.
Blok flütle Fikret Kızılok çalarak
annemi taciz ettiğim yıllarda da oradaydı.
Hep oradaydı aslında.
Ama ben onu hiçbir zaman
insanların önüne çıkarmak istememiştim.
Umutlarımın kırılmasından
çok korkuyordum çünkü.
En sevdiğim şeydi o çünkü.
Eğer o da kırılırsa ben ayakta
durabileceğime inanmıyordum çünkü,
ama o kadar güzel bir buluşma
ve karşılaşma oldu ki
umutlarımın kırılması ne demek,
geçmişte kırılan umutlarım onarıldı
ve dünyaya dair
o kadar yeni kanallar açıldı,
o kadar büyük bir inançla doldum ki
çünkü Zonguldak'tan Isparta'ya,
Diyarbakır'dan Brüksel'e uzanan
bir yolda harika insanlarla tanıştım,
ben dünyada bu kadar iyi
insan olduğunu bilmiyordum.
Genelde böyle tanıştığım insanlar beni
hep hayal kırıklığına uğrattıkları için,
harika insanlarla tanıştım
ve bana çok gerçek hikâyeler anlattılar.
Hamile bir anne yanında çocuğuyla
konsere gelmişti,
bana çok güzel bir hikâye anlattı.
70 yaşında bir büyükanne vardı,
dişleri yok böyle başörtüsü var.
Geldi böyle,
"Kızım ben Haydi Söyle'yi
çok seviyorum," dedi.
"Şaşırmadım anneannem,
gel öpeyim," dedim.
(Kahkaha)
Çünkü o onu sevecek tabii ki
onun duygusu, onun ruhu
ona çok hitap edecek.
Yani Taşikardi'de dans etmeyebilir
tabii büyükannemiz, yani normal.
O kadar tatlı insanlarla tanıştım ki!
Sulukule Gönüllüleri ile tanıştım.
Rehber Köpekler Derneği için çalışan
o dünya güzeli âmâ avukatla tanıştım.
Çanakkale'de çatıları yıkılmış
evlerin çatılarına
güneş panelleri kurmak isteyen
avukatlarla tanıştım.
Ondan sonracığıma, Zonguldak'ta
hep birlikte böyle çalışma grubu kurup
parklarda benim şarkılarla dans eden
dünya güzeli ergenlerle tanıştım.
Diş tellerinden artık utanmadığını
söyleyen genç kızlarla,
genç erkeklerle tanıştım.
Kendi cinsinden birini sevdiği için el ele
özgürce sokaklarda yürüyemediği hâlde
artık el ele özgürce yürüme cesaretini
bir şarkıdan aldığını söyleyen
insanlarla tanıştım
ve bu, bana çok cesaret ve umut verdi.
Bu yolculuk bana çok umut veriyor,
yani ben burada
size teşekkür etmek için varım bugün,
umutla ilgili
çok bir şey bildiğim için değil.
(Alkış) Sağ olun.
Bildiğim bir şeyi yapacağım şimdi,
konuşmaktan daha iyi olur umarım.
Sağ olun, çok heyecanlıyım hâlâ.
Bizim biraz umuttan
bahsetmemiz lazım, değil mi?
Hep mutsuzluktan, karamsarlıktan,
ülkesiz kalmış insanlardan,
fakirlikten, yalnızlıktan, hüzünden,
birbirimizi kırdığımızdan,
birbirimize saldırdığımızdan,
birbirimize artık
tahammülümüzün olmadığından,
onun öteki olduğundan,
bunun yabancı olduğundan
bahsetmeye çok mu alıştık?
Alışmadık.
Bizim umuttan bahsetmemiz lazım.
[Müzik başlar]
♪ Falımdan bir bilet çıktı ♪
♪ Filmin adı Al Yazmalı ♪
♪ Gören var mı diye baktım ♪
♪ Yoktu ♪
♪ Filmin sonu çok zordu ♪
♪ Kimse görmez dedin usulca ♪
♪ Yoktun, bırakamadım bulunca ♪
♪ Yağmur başladı hâlimi sorarken ♪
♪ İyiyim dedim, yalan söyledim ♪
♪ Hatırlar mısın geniş ferah meydanları ♪
♪ Savaşsız ve sakin akşamları ♪
♪ Kafesteki bülbülleri ♪
♪ Yamuk kesilmiş kâkülleri ♪
♪ Göğe baktıran balkonları ♪
♪ Hiç unutmadım dedim ♪
♪ Islak gülümsedin ıslık çalarak ♪
♪ Hayal ettim bölüştüğümüzü
Bir ekmeği oturarak ♪
♪ El ele
Diz dize ♪
♪ Ve göz göze
Bakışarak ♪
♪ Hiç ölmeden ♪
♪ Sonsuza kadar ♪
♪ Uzattın cebinden bileti ♪
♪ Çekerken elimden elini ♪
♪ Vazgeçtim bana yetmez artık ♪
♪ Kapadım o yara defterini ♪
♪ Ve işte böyledir ♪
♪ Küçük, kayıp, kısa, ayıp ♪
♪ Yalan yanlış bir aşkın hikâyesi ♪
♪ Ve işte böyledir ♪
♪ Küçük, kayıp, kısa, ayıp, ♪
♪ Yalan yanlış bir aşkın hikâyesi ♪
♪ Herkesi kandırır gölgesi ♪
(Müzik sona erer)
(Alkış)
İnsanlar toplumlara, toplumlar devletlere
ve devletler birbirlerine...
Umut zincirimiz çok uzun
ve hepimiz doğaya bağlıyız.
O yüzden birbirimize çok iyi davranalım,
sınırlarımızı aşalım
ve hepimizin aynı dünyanın insanı
olduğumuzu hatırlayalım her an,
sizi çok seviyorum, sağ olun.
(Alkış)